keeping our distance to sanitizing our
hands
kovid 19 has transformed the way we all
shop now the latest measure
is to become law anyone not wearing a
face mask in a shop in
england from next friday could be fined
100 pounds will you be happy to wear one
i i've got mixed feelings to be honest
with you like i said i'm not sure of the
effectiveness i
wonder whether increases people's
anxiety and fear rather than reducing it
actually
when i leave the house it's just got
into my practice now to grab a mask
we've been open the whole time at the
bank and
customers coming in a lot not wearing
anything
it puts us as a risk obviously you're
protecting yourself and you're
protecting others
in case i don't know if i felt it i hope
not but
i could be a carrier couldn't i
at the key cutters in bedminster in
bristol
face masks pose yet another challenge
with three four months not opening i
need
i need the trade i will again try to
implement it where i can regards the
mask
but i've also got a balancing act with
regards
livelihood it's not going to be down to
shop owners to make sure that their
customers are wearing masks it'll be up
to the police to enforce
the new rule but some say that
responsibility
is unrealistic and unfair
like all lockdown measures police will
be relying on the public to comply
i think stores need to play their part
but if you don't have a face covering
you don't go in the store because that's
not complying with the law and in those
extreme situations where we have to be
called
then we will attend we will deal with
what we have the new rule will bring
england in line with scotland and other
countries like germany
spain and italy we're in a completely
different
part of the epidemic now where there's
relatively little virus around
but what virus is around we can't see
and wearing masks
is all about protecting other people
kovid 19 has hit the high street hard
the government hopes masks will give
more people the confidence to return
and keep shops alive dan whitehead sky
news
in bristol